[Music]
well
i overheard my husband's friends
and him
making fun of me she insisted on asking
him if he felt like he had downgraded on
his ex and he said
maybe oh
gosh
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone show
dan it's good to see you it's good to be
with you
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at
[Music]
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
and uh leave a message it'll go to an
answering machine leave a message let us
know what's going on and we will haul
the batgirl at you unless you ain't a
hell of a bad girl and then i don't know
what we're going to do
um or you go to johndaloni.com
ask a-s-k
and you can fill it in
um also if you've got
good news
send that please please and good news
the show is so heavy
and uh we want to have some good news if
you got somebody in your life that's
awesome and you want to write a letter
about them i'll read it on the air send
it or if you want to send me uh mail
uh
man i used to get handwritten letters
all the time and i've gotten a few of
them so send me some letters i like
getting mail it's just fun it's like
it's the 1400s or something
um
it's not really it's like it's the 90s i
guess anyway
if you want to be on the show give us a
buzz looking forward to it let's get
right to the phones let's go to michael
in
dude here in town what's up michael
hey john how are you doing this morning
partying brother what are you up to
uh well i'm out at work and i feel like
i'm swimming in a hot tub because of how
humid it is but um i'm getting through
it so it would be really cool if you
actually
clean hot tubs for a living and you're
actually swimming in a hot tub but i get
what you're saying i'd rather not
honestly
that was a terrible joke i just made man
that was brutal sorry all right so
what's up dude
no hot tub related questions but what's
up
yeah so um pretty simple question uh
luckily for you it's not a dark topic
somewhat or is somewhat happy today um
kind of forward so um the question's
about my girlfriend and i
we're both in college she's going to
graduate
and this december it looks like and i'll
be graduating summer 2023 what are you
studying man and
i'm doing business administration and
right now she's doing uh
political science and she's gonna end up
going to law school so we've we actually
both met you uh in 2019 so i'll leave it
at that
did i did i visit was i speaking at your
school or did i work at your school
you did yeah
very cool man was it was i lame
probably kind of no no you're awesome
actually my mom was like so impressed to
you she actually i can't remember
i think we talked to you in one of the
buildings after and you're like oh i'm
so happy that it went wrong
i don't want to be impressed by you i
mean about your mom all right then
everybody
yeah yeah okay cool i'm glad that i
wasn't an idiot in 2019 there's other
people who could call and be like i knew
you in 2019 you're a [ __ ] but that
makes me happy michael all right so you
and your girlfriend she's about to go to
law school about to graduate you're
gonna graduate in a year or so
um okay so what's up
so we've been dating about seven months
we're both christians and um
i'll get to the question here so we both
want to know how to go about like
waiting till marriage um with intimacy
um and how to live a clean relationship
um how like we should hold each other
accountable how we should set boundaries
that type of thing and the reason i'm
i'm kind of the one asking this more
than she is i guess i kind of brought it
up but the reason is i've never really
had
like a serious relationship i mean i'm
in my 20s now so i'm taking stuff more
seriously like long term
shoes as well the only other
relationship i've had was in high school
like five years ago and it's lasted a
few months so um
this is kind of a new road for me and um
actually going about setting boundaries
or kind of holding each other
accountable in that sense
just kind of wondering what your
thoughts were with that cool man so
first and foremost
um
good for you for setting boundaries and
saying hey this is a
uh value of mine and this is the value
of hers and we're gonna have this
discussion here's why this is super
important let's say she ends up being
the person that you
marry
these values discussions will come up
over and over for the rest of your life
and so developing now a framework for
how are we going to engage in
values-based conversations is incredible
if she doesn't um
and by the way like values meaning is
mom gonna come live with us her dad's
gonna come live with us or are we gonna
still talk to mom or dad if they get
divorced or how are we gonna raise kids
or
do we gonna get this streaming service i
mean all these different values are
gonna come up over and over and over and
over and over again um the second thing
is if you all break up
i want to say i
almost i almost said if you all break up
great i don't mean great like that right
great i hope y'all don't i hope it all
works out
um but
you will have
had a hard conversation like a values
based conversation which is just super
important to have okay so before i
answer this i want to challenge one word
that you said okay and i wrote it down
here
okay
i don't like characterizing any i don't
like characterizing relationships in
clean or dirty
okay
okay and so
the clean is often a
derivative of pure
right and i get the sentiment in
christian circles used generally right
and and it can be any relationship i
want to keep it quote unquote pure
by not fill in the blank when it comes
to sexual activity okay
um
there's just a lot of downstream baggage
because what ends up happening is
if y'all end up making out one night and
it crosses a line that y'all had to set
as a value
are you now unclean are you now unpure
are you now dirty what do you have to do
right and so now we're getting all this
identity so i want to back out of that
language for a second okay and
i want to wrap the language around
honoring and consent okay
and so the way i'd approach this
conversation quite honestly is pretty
simple and i wouldn't overthink it i
would have a conversation and said what
are you comfortable with and i need to
tell you what i'm comfortable with
that's that's her telling you her needs
and you telling her your needs
and saying here's where i'm not willing
to compromise and where are you not
willing to compromise what's okay what's
not okay and this is who we are moving
forward and since we're christians and
we decide that we want to
um not sleep together until we're
married what does that actually mean
i've met people who don't hold hands
i've met rights i've met people all the
way down the continent like so what does
that actually mean for y'all
and then it comes to uh so we're talking
about consent what's okay what's not
okay
and then we're gonna talk about um
how we're gonna hold each other
accountable i don't wanna overthink that
just don't put yourself in that
situation right so people are often like
yeah but how do i you know just
you don't mean to open yourself a
situation
um
the more you overthink it the more
likely you're to create some really
complex system and the more complex the
system as the greatness seemed to lab
says the more likely it is that system
will fail you okay right so make it
pretty cut and dry clean and simple
she said this is her values this is her
lines this is my these are my values or
my lines
and if we feel like we're about to cross
one of those lines we're gonna stop
someone's gonna pull the ripcord
someone's gonna say
that's enough and i'm not gonna get my
feelings hurt i'm not gonna get mad i'm
gonna honor right i'm gonna be about
honoring her needs she's gonna be
honoring my needs and we're gonna move
forward with this thing so really it's
about having the hard conversation up
front which is hey this is a value of
mine
and this is a value of hers so let's
create some boundaries and create them
together i can give you some but they
end up sounding like i'm some kind of
80s youth minister okay
um and i don't want to be that guy but i
mean
if you're trying not to
have sex with your girlfriend of seven
months or a year then don't put yourself
in situations where you're gonna have
sex with your you could have you see
what i'm saying
right it's it's not it's as not complex
as that so
i gave you a
kind of a simple answer
uh hopefully i'm not bi i'm not skirting
the issue
ask me more direct questions if if i
didn't get there
no that i mean that's pretty much it um
we just like there's been like times
where i'm like ah man like yeah that got
close or you know something like that
and i feel like some guilt over it um
kind of like oh man i shouldn't have
done that and then kind of like sticks
with me for a little bit
and then it finally like passes over and
i'm like you know what let's just move
on like it happened you know moving
forward how do i not
do that here's what's important
remember the old brene brown quote
shame eat secrets for breakfast
if you cross a line
an established value line between you
and your romantic partner between you
and your business partner between you
and your professor between you and your
parents whatever that is
you cross somebody's value line
you don't just
wait till it passes
you address it
hey last night we were making out and we
got this line and we both flew past the
our our our value line
and we found ourselves in way deeper
water than we meant to
and we almost crossed our ultimate
boundary line that we've set for
ourselves
um
i'm sorry if i put you in an
uncomfortable position
and let her speak back to you and she
might say i'm sorry for putting you in
an uncomfortable position and then y'all
can say
what do we want to do next
right
not just you go home and be quiet she
goes home and be quiet and it's quiet
and you both just don't address it
because here's the thing that will that
will resurface at some point and it
might resurface five years down the road
10 years down the road 15 years down the
road it will resurface so have the
conversation okay
um are you in a position to do that with
her you feel safe enough to do it yeah
great yeah and we and we've done things
similar to that um but hearing you say
it kind of
you know it's kind of like one of those
things where like i oh i've done that
but now that i hear like you explain it
it kind of puts
even like what i've done in a more clear
sense of how to go about doing it i
guess so let me let me so it's
people listening to this are gonna have
a few reactions one what a bunch of
idiots they're been dating for a year or
seven months in college like why what
to
the um
whatever branch of christianity they'll
come at you for all different angles for
all the right right so i want to take it
out of sex because sex is a highly it's
just a charged conversation
and let's take it over to another
situation um
in college i was a hothead
i was a loudmouth big shocker right
and i've actually had quite a bit of
transformation personally and how i used
to be is to be a loudmouth [ __ ]
um way more so than i am now
and
if i was at a concert and i was with my
wife who was my girlfriend then i was
with any woman at a concert
one of my great stories is i i saw
somebody
um like body check a a woman i saw a big
guy body check a woman in the middle of
a like a it's not really a mosh pit but
kind of
and i
just snapped i sprinted across the room
and it was funny because another guy who
ended up being friends with he was on
the other side of the room and saw it
from the other side and we both ended up
right so i was that guy i was trying to
be social justice guy all the time and
defending people but i was always
looking for fights
and
especially when i was with my girlfriend
like it was my job to be where
and one day my wife said
or who the woman is my wife is not my
girlfriend she said i feel less safe
when you act like that
and i was like what
right that was one of i was one of my
values was to protect and defend and
show honor and all this stupid nonsense
macho bullcrap
and her value was she wants to date
somebody and marry somebody who makes
her feel safe and me running around
looking for fights or looking for
something to get involved in to be tough
that made her feel less safe
and so suddenly
i had to change my actions i had to
change my behaviors we had to sit down
and talk about this because i thought i
was doing something right that we were
on the same page we were not okay
and
i'm pointing that back to you now one or
both of you may have crossed a value
line y'all set for yourselves and one of
both of you she might thought i thought
oh maybe he doesn't want to have this
value with anymore and he wants to sleep
with me tonight so okay i'm in or you
had that thought or maybe you thought oh
i know we set this boundary but maybe we
can just keep pushing and pushing it
you got to go back and both of you have
to be honest with one another like my
girlfriend who's not my wife did to me
like i feel less safe and i know you're
trying to keep me safe but the way
you're trying to keep me safe makes me
feel less safe
so here's how i would feel more safe if
you see a fight about to happen then you
grab my hand and we leave that makes me
feel very safe that makes me feel like
you are honoring me and i was like oh
okay so you all have that similar
conversation
when i'm when i one of y'all starts
hitting the gas on it
it makes me it would honor me more if
you stood up and said hey let's go for a
walk
okay you see what i'm saying
yes sir let's have the conversation
about the values and by the way
let's get at at the end of the day why
do we want to honor one another until
we're married if we're trying to keep up
just a behavior it's gonna always fall
flat is it to honor your faith heritage
or is there a level deeper than that
it's to honor the person i'm with or
it's to honor the institution of
marriage or it's on like why are you
doing these things have that
conversation with one another why are we
doing this
what's the point of this value
and then let's go from there
awesome michael i'm hey i'm
it's awesome that you're this age having
conversations with other people that you
care about about values and about how
we're going to live these values out
don't overthink them and make them about
consent and honor
okay
man she's lucky to have you
talk to you soon we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to mel in
fort worth what's up mel
hey dr john how are you partying i'm not
partying i'm at work i'm not i don't
know why i say that all the time i'm
doing great how about you
we're doing really good really really
good awesome all right so what's up okay
okay so um my husband and i feel really
strong about being a family that always
tells the truth but in age-appropriate
ways so that we're kind of always
exchanging innocence for wisdom love it
um so we spend a lot of time because my
family lives all over the world we talk
a lot about my family and my husband's
family so my seven-year-old has a really
strong sense of family with relatives he
barely ever sees
and he's also learning our history which
is pretty cool
but the issue that we're now facing is
my son is asking a lot of questions
about my dad
and my husband and i don't know how to
answer his
questions about his death in an
age-appropriate way because
the truth about
his death is really heavy that most
adults
have a really hard time grasping okay
um and for that reason my siblings have
chosen to tell their kids an alternative
ending
but that doesn't that doesn't sit right
with my husband and i
um
i also feel like i might be a little bit
further along in my healing process with
all of it like i'm really well and whole
and complete in who i am today
um and i want my son to be able to kind
of see
what can happen on the other side of
living through unimaginable
circumstances okay um so a quick picture
of my dad um he was a child who grew up
during the last world war
um his family managed to escape they
were the first family in many months not
to be shot
leaving behind half of one extended
family and we've never ever talked to
that side ever again
um so that really affected him growing
up and then when i was a kid he was
finally diagnosed with being bipolar
um he had
psychiatrists he took medication but it
didn't really help at all so living
under his house was very
scary and very unpredictable yeah
and then when i was 17
he laid out all his personal effects on
the bed
around dinner time because that's when
he knew my mom would call for him and
he went into the backyard and set
himself on fire
so my husband and i want to be very
careful
and mindful about how we choose to share
this with my son
who's seven and he's
seven i'm a big boy i can know
information i'm really brave mom
um i'm not afraid to say that he took
his own life and they had mental illness
i know how to talk about that stuff
it's the follow-up questions
that
we feel really lost on how
how to answer that yeah
so i'm going to answer that really quick
and then we'll circle back okay
yeah the quick of it is
is when you're telling a seven-year-old
something you're not not telling them
you are taking ownership of what you
want to talk about
and you're modeling for them
that you have autonomy over the things
that you want to think about and talk
about which is a gift
it's one of the cornerstones of being
mentally well
and so instead of saying um you're only
seven you're too young we'll tell you
when you get older instead of saying
that
um it is
it's was really painful for mommy
and i'm choosing to not talk about it
right now one day i'll talk about it but
today i'm choosing to not talk about it
and that conversation is over
yeah and that is a gift to your kid
yeah
and kudos to you high five to you
somersaults and cartwheels to you for
not lying to your children there will be
held to pay for your brothers and
sisters choices
and it will come out in weird ways
but a fundamental
piece of their core identity they've
chosen to hide which perpetuates trauma
and
um
when you say they were shot was was
there a history like in concentration
camps
um they uh they uh escaped through a
border through the woods okay and mike
yeah so the studies were actually done
on that community
that lived through that mess
yeah discussed generational trauma that
comes from
just living and breathing and drinking
the water of pure evil which is what
people who survived the holocaust the
whole mess had to do
and
um and so there's there
yeah they're kicking the can down the
road
and good to for you guys for not so
you're gonna balance that with
um by the way i the language i would use
is daddy um
you're my dad granddad died by suicide
which is different than he took his own
life right
dad died by suicide he's very very sick
and
i don't really want to talk about it
anymore well how what did he do i don't
choose to talk about that right now one
day i will but it still makes me very
sad and i'm just going to end it right
there
i'm not going to apologize i'm not gonna
explain or whatever and you are teaching
your child a powerful lesson there
um circling back
lighting yourself on fire
is
a middle finger
is it not yeah
yeah it was it was totally he was
practicing the day before the neighbor
saw small fires in the day it was a big
f u because my siblings and i all put
down boundaries with him because he was
so toxic and unwell
um
that i had stopped talking to him a year
and a half before he died and we live in
the same house because he was just so
unhealthy yeah and um and
you're you're healed from that
yeah
yeah good yeah i'm totally healed from
that i just you're able to talk to me
about it your heart's not beating faster
right now
yeah no like i'm
i'm i want to be able to tell my son the
truth because
who i am on the other side of this is is
pretty
unusual so let me tell you this here
here's the important
and i know i'm asking you to walk a
razor's edge here this is hard okay yeah
don't make your need to tell
a burden that your child has to carry
absolutely okay and there's a fine line
there between i don't want to tell the
truth and he can't know this because
he's only seven and he does not need a
picture of a burning man in the backyard
he doesn't need that in his head okay
one day you can have that hard
conversation that's a that's a much
later in life hard conversation yes i
agree but do you have any guidance for
when i when we have that conversation
because we're not he's not
age-appropriate now yeah exactly um i
would
kind of thinking about it like a like a
gas pedal i'm slowly or maybe depressing
the gas pedal or slowly letting the gas
off right so i'm gonna start with daddy
died my dad died and i don't choose to
talk about it when they're three or four
and maybe six or seven or eight
depending on the wisdom of a child that
every kid is differently i have
different conversations with my son than
i do with my daughter just do right
and um death for my daughter was pretty
abstract
late until i mean she was
five or six
my son's beloved dog died when he was
three and a half
and we took that dog out into my buddy's
ranch and we dug the hole ourselves and
we prayed over that dog and we sung to
that dog and we talked about it and we
buried that dog together my son had a
visceral experience with death when he
was three and a half
and what was beautiful was that was a
touchstone for us for years still is
remember how and then we went to the
first funeral
but when does granddad get up
remember back with maria the dog
um grandma's not going to get up because
he's passed away he's dead now and so we
were able to like oh okay right so it
became a touchdown became an important
part my daughter
i wasn't going to kill something just to
show her a dead body right and her first
experience was a funeral and that was
that's been hard for her because she's
told me i still see that picture my son
doesn't have that he didn't have that
replay she does and so i know i'm gonna
be a little more sensitive as she gets
older but then maybe 12 15 16
somebody in your son's life might die by
suicide right or somebody's parent might
pass
then it will be was it a gun no it was a
pretty violent it was pretty rough for
us to watch it was hard
really hard it was very graphic and
again i'm still not going to say that
i'm thinking 16 17 18 before i say they
lit themselves on fire
right yeah absolutely and that's gonna
be mental health like i wanna make sure
my kids are okay and they are not
struggling with anxiety or depression or
or or right i might also begin to give
them a context of their history here's
some of the things that granddad
experienced
right yeah
and what you'll like here's some stories
or here's uh like a children's book
about or here's some of grandma's
letters or something like that we're
gonna create a
whole
i don't want to tell the story by itself
in isolation does that make sense
yes i want to tell the story as a
continuing narrative of here's the life
here's the the family tree from which
you come from
yeah and you can handle you can not deal
with the trauma and you can be so buried
underneath it and not get help and not
do the xyz
and
or
mommy put in the work mommy works really
really really hard and this is what
healing can look like see what i'm
saying
yeah i feel like we've done a pretty
good job of leaving enough breadcrumbs
um to get a picture and a sense of a lot
of the stuff it's just we've
he's asked and i said it's complicated
and um i'm just not ready to talk about
that with you yet and you know i won't
lie to you i'll always tell you the
truth but there's just some things that
aren't you know
i'll tell you when we're ready tell them
what makes you feel
so he knows he's not crazy tell him it
still makes mommy sad
yeah tell them that that when i was when
mommy was was a child how old were you
uh when he died he was 17. i was 17.
yeah tell her that mommy was still a
child when it happened i was still a kid
and it made mommy very scared
and very sad and i don't want to talk
about it right now
and the idea that he's that would give
him permission to be sad and to be
scared about things because my mommy was
look how tough she is now you see what
i'm saying
tell him how you feel not just
don't make it a math problem make it a
human problem
yeah
which is i i can't tell you he's so
lucky to have you
man what a gift
such a blessing man it's awesome um no
dude you're you're yeah you're doing it
great and the idea that you're
giving him a picture of what healing
looks like oh
man it's hard the road you've been down
is hard hard hard and let me tell you
this
as he approaches 17
14 15 16 it wouldn't surprise me if your
body starts settling the alarms don't be
afraid to continue to stay well and to
continue to do the things that you need
to do to stay well and to get ahead of
things
um if i'm you when he turns 13 14 i'm
probably gonna go make an appointment
with the counselor just to do it just
check in
get the engine run over right checked
over
but i'm gonna be about
modeling what wellness looks like and
healing looks like because your body's
going to set off on you again when it
remembers like i remember this i
remember this let's get ahead of that
thing and continue to paint such a
beautiful picture of healing
and man
just so you know this
generationally down the road
people are going to live differently
because of the work you're putting in
right now such a gift we'll be right
back
hey what's up daloni here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video
phone and even live chat sessions with
you and your therapist you never have to
even see anyone on camera if you don't
want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back let's go to emma
in
welcome to miami what's up emma
hi dr john how are we doing
um i'm doing okay oh so not good at all
not good at all
a little bad
okay so fill me in i'm sorry what's
going on
well
i overheard my husband's friends
him
making fun of me
oh man what about
uh well first of all we're newlyweds
after our honeymoon my husband and his
friends were having a group video call
i chatted with them for a bit and then i
excused myself to go for a walk
then i made the biggest mistake of my
life
i forgot something
and turned back to get it
but everyone had thought that i'd left
his friends had started to ask him
about our honeymoon
and started poking fun at him
eventually one of his friends
asked him if
if
if my looks were still a problem
for him
he told her he loved me and that we had
a great honeymoon
and that
hold on
he told her
yeah
all right sorry i would interrupt you
continue
yeah we it was a group of them
so so he told her that you know i'm
beautiful on the inside
despite you know him liking
lighter-skinned slimmer girls
he told them that
we can't have it all you know
she insisted on asking him if
he felt like he had downgraded from his
ex oh jeez yeah who who was yeah
light-skinned and slim
and he said
maybe oh but he said that
he said that but i make him happy
and another one of his friends i'm not
sure if she was trying to help
said that
maybe it would help a lot if i had lost
some weight i'm i'm not morbidly obese
or
maybe a little chubby
but right now um nothing feels the same
anymore
and
i've been ruminating wishing that i
didn't turn back
hold on hold on hold on hey emma
you did not make the biggest mistake of
your life
okay
you didn't
and i'm heartbroken that this is how you
ended up with this info
but you didn't make a mistake you didn't
screw up anything here okay
you
my friend are not at fault here okay
now i'm not saying you're perfect and
i'm not saying you're not doing right
you know i'm saying but you didn't screw
this up okay
you're allowed to walk into your own
home that you share with your husband
and
yeah
i'm just like my stomach's dropped i
could just i can't imagine the hurt
you're feeling right now
um
so how long ago was this
five weeks ago
and so my
here's a couple of
uh
so he's not here okay
and i've got all kinds of thoughts and
all kinds of things running through my
head but he's not here um
so the only person i can talk to right
now is you is that cool
so
it would be easy for me to join you and
piling up on him
but this call is about you and your
wellness okay
and so
um
my first question to you is have you
told him
i i haven't i
i feel embarrassed for turning back
and
listening
as well and
he would feel bad about it i guess he
should he should you don't need to
protect him he's a grown man if he's
going to be telling his friends and a
bunch of women
that um
yeah yeah i had to go with jv here when
it comes to the looks department
um
then
he can be a grown man and look you in
the eye
see what i'm saying you didn't screw up
you don't need to defend him
he's clearly okay with having
conversations about you and your body
out to the public
um
the only person he's not having them
with is you
right
yeah but but how
it wouldn't change
anything because that's how he truly
feels
right and so the next the next question
change
certain
of my characteristics or
or what society
calls physical attractiveness i can lose
weight
but
there are other things that i just
cannot change about myself
emma mmm
man
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
here's here's the challenge you find
yourself in okay
he's not telling you the truth about how
he feels about you
and you're not telling him the truth
about what you know
and what's going to happen in short
order if it hasn't happened already
is that within your home
you live with a threat now
and you're gonna create a special safe
cocoon that only you live in
and he's not gonna know what it is he's
just gonna know that his wife is distant
from him
and
then he's gonna be about solving that
distance with any number of ways if he's
a person of character he will
continually try to reach out to appeal
to your heart and say why is there
distance between us
and if you don't tell him you're
choosing to respond to his lack of
character with dishonesty
or he might choose to
be a scumbag and approach that
or
try to solve that distance between the
two of you by going back to these other
women that he has on his video chats and
tell them whatever and try to create
connections with them
okay
but the reality is there's a huge gap in
your marriage and no having the
conversation isn't gonna solve how he
feels
who cares this isn't about society
and this quite honestly isn't about the
people on the chat
this is about your husband
and this is about you
this is about your marriage and right
now you don't feel safe in your own home
you don't feel safe in your own skin
right
you can't live
moving forward with this ambiguity
but
can he really love me if
i'm not attractive
so when when
here's the challenge
you heard part of a conversation that
sounds awful and i would love to talk to
him on the phone one day man i'd love to
have this dude on the show
um i'd like to talk to this dude in
private quite honestly not in the macho
kind of way but i'd like to have a
conversation with this dude
bonehead
um
but here's the reality here's reality is
is since as mad as i am
and as sensitive as a topic as this
you heard a part of a conversation
and you have created an entire narrative
around the part of the conversation you
have without going to him and saying hey
this is what i heard
is that fair
yeah
so
my wife did not marry brad pitt
close close yes she didn't
right
and
i imagine
i know there are because she has told me
that i look feral sometimes well that is
true i don't when i get in hunting
season i don't always bathe and shave
and shower anyway
so there are seasons when
right and then there's times that she
says man when you're dressed up in a she
said the worst part about my new job is
that when i was working at universities
i wore a suit and tie every day and
she's like dude you look good like you
look real good and now you just wear
t-shirts and you kind of look like a
slob
right so here's what i'm telling you i'm
trying to make i'm trying to lighten
this our conversation a little bit but
yes
she might have a perfect picture in her
head of a professional basketball player
who's six six and has great calves and
super great muscle i'm not that guy
but she'll also tell you that she thinks
i'm handsome and she thinks i'm really
good looking
right
that's less of the issue to me the
bigger issue to me is a deep violation
of trust
that your
husband
did not talk to you
and has not been honest with you
and
either that or
when he's trying to be the cool guy with
his friends
who are bagging on you and he doesn't
come to your defense
or maybe he felt like he was coming to
your defense by saying yeah you know
what she doesn't look perfect but i love
her and he doesn't understand how much
that hurts you
see what i'm saying
and he doesn't understand the
existential tale spin that you are in
because you married a man that does not
believe you are beautiful
and nobody i don't care who you are
nobody wants to be married to someone
who doesn't believe they're beautiful
inside now right
yeah
so i think
here's what i don't want you to do
i don't want you to avoid this
conversation and wake up in five years
and still believe that you're married to
a guy that doesn't find you beautiful
and it's less about him
it's more about you don't feel beautiful
in his presence you see what i'm saying
that's different
what does he think or is yeah exactly
how embarrassing is that
and
i just yeah oh god what
i don't talk bad about your husband but
what an idiot good grief man
um and here's the other side
i also think it's important for men to
have
guy friends
that they can
sit down and have hard truth
conversations with
right
because i don't want a generation of men
who grow up living in silence and then
just end up sitting in a recliner
cracking a beer every night just to get
through the day they got to have people
that they talk about hard things with
but those things that they talk about
their friends have got to especially
when it talks about their wife and their
wife's body or their girlfriends and
their sexuality man there's got to be
some consensus about what's cool to talk
about what's not
and where i am and where i'm not
unfortunately you've probably heard me
say this if you listen to this show not
by your hand but in your lap
you didn't ask for this
and you walked in your home which you do
not have to apologize for and you heard
your talk your husband talking in a
public space in your home that you do
not have to apologize for and you
re-entered a conversation you were just
in
before you went out for your walk you
just talked to these two-faced people
who were like oh hi great to see you oh
my gosh how are you still right
you had
no fault in this zero
and i'll say fault but i don't really
mean it the only fault you've had now
i don't want to say fault because i
think you're processing traumas what's
happening you're processing
really heaviness
i
the only fault here is that you haven't
sitting down and said i heard this and
this hurt me in this way
and so what i would tell you is don't
let your husband's uh failures here
rob you of your character and of your
beauty and of your strength
okay
you're worth being loved and you're
worth being believed you are beautiful i
don't care what society's that stuff's
nonsense man
it's nonsense
and it man it may be that your husband
is just a sweet loving guy who's an
absolute boneheaded [ __ ]
there's a lot of men who are like young
men who like that need to be taught he
may be an absolute character-free idiot
and your life would be better if you
made some hard decisions you see what
i'm saying
yeah
um
okay i just do a lot at you tell me
where you are
well if we were dating i know
i would have left him
okay
what's the best move what's the best
move for emma to make emma feel safe
make emma feel loved
let emma know that she is beautiful
what's the next step
i guess to accept this and move on
emma have you listened to anything
no
we're not accepting this no listen we're
not accepting this and moving on
okay
are you in an abusive relationship are
you safe no
yeah i am okay
if you hadn't heard this conversation
would you think he loves you deeply
i would okay
i really would
is he worth a conversation
i would want to think so are you worth
that conversation
yes okay
do you promise me
you will confront this head-on directly
i will
here's what i want you to do before you
have that that meeting
i want you to write down what you heard
i want you to write down how you feel
because what he's going to say is this
no you are not a supermodel but i
married you i gave you my everything i
love you
our sex life is good our honeymoon was
great i love you everything about what
i'm demonstrating here says i love you
and that's when you're gonna start
feeling crazy and so i want you to have
already written down so you can read
yeah but you told a group of people that
i wasn't beautiful
and now i will for the rest of my life
wondered does my husband wish he was
somebody else
you told a group of women
before because they were checking back
in right
right it would seem as if they they've
had this conversation before yes
you regularly had conversations with
other men and women
about not being attracted to me or about
my body not being enough
i need you to understand what that did
to my insides
to who i look in the mirror and see now
because now you became just another
faceless person in society who judges me
because my skin's too dark who judges me
because i don't fit in a size fill in
the blank who judges me because
and you were supposed to be my safe
place
that's why we got married
you were my safe place and i was yours
and you're not safe anymore you're just
like one of them
okay i want him to hear that
and in every marriage there has to be
space there has been times when my wife
sat down and said
hey
physical fitness john is a big deal to
you and your mental health and if you
don't exercise you don't think clearly
and if you're not exercising and eating
right you're not okay
and i've noticed like
you're having to wear xl shirts now like
you've gotten you've put on a lot of
weight
um i'm worried about you
big picture
right
my we've had that conversation and i
gave her permission to get to have that
conversation with me but that's
different than i ain't attracted to you
because you're too bi you see what i'm
saying there's a very big difference and
so i don't want people to listen to this
and say oh so you're not ever no you're
allowed to have hard conversations
you have to have hard conversations
right or i'm struggling with attraction
right now and here's why but that
conversation goes directly to you in a
spirit of love and connection not a
spirit of blame and judgment and
especially doesn't go to all my buddies
first and by the way guys listen to this
nobody needs to know what happened on
your freaking honeymoon shut up that's
yours good grief keep something sacred
for crying out loud you idiots
jesus
i got the greatest guy friends on planet
earth the greatest guys on planet they
know everything about me you know what
they don't know
what happened on my honeymoon because
that's mine that's me and my wife right
good grief this is ridiculous all i have
to say
i'm starting to get mad again
i want you to write that stuff out and i
want you to let him know hey we need to
have a hard conversation
okay and here's the thing
emma if you don't want to be married to
him anymore
or you need some space from him
you need to be honest with him about
that
conversation okay okay
if you want to stay married to him but
you don't know how just yet
i want you to be honest about that
conversation like you told me if you
were dating this is over i'd be out of
here
but i said for better or worse and we
have to figure this out
unless this is past or worse you see
what i'm saying
yeah you may need a girlfriend to sit
with you and walk you through this all
right and well i mean not walk you
through it but sit there with you while
you do this okay but
this conversation is really important
and then what happens next is really
important okay
okay okay
i'll ask you one more time do you
believe you're worth this conversation
i am do you believe him
um that you deserve a safe place
i do okay
i'm so so sorry this happened to you do
you believe you have zero none none no
fault in walking into your own home
99
0. got it
got it
yeah zero okay
i will tell you this
the spirit of the person i'm talking to
is
stunning
okay
thank you
stunning
and
nobody gets another judgment on you got
it
you're on my you're on my team now
cool
thank you all right um do me this huge
favor
let me know when you've had this
conversation write us back
let us know how it goes
and if he wants to be on the show if you
want both won't be on the show about
what next i'd love to have you back
and if he doesn't
cool
before i let you go i have to be honest
about this you may have this
conversation he may be sick he may say
you're right i made a mistake we
shouldn't have got married
that could happen
it'll be devastating and hard
and if that happens
no that's walking into that room and
hearing that conversation
was the greatest thing that ever
happened to you
because you shed yourself of this idiot
and you will find someone who believes
in you and who believes that you're
beautiful and is thinks
god every day that they found you
that person exists
those people exist not just one person
like a needle in haystack there's
bajillions of people
and if you have this hard conversation
and he gets down on both knees and says
i screwed up bad
here's what i meant i didn't defend you
well i screwed it up because i was a
coward and i'm gonna do better and let
me tell you i've been there
i wish i could say things differently
and i've had to say i screwed this up
and i was a coward and i was a wimp and
i fill in the blank here i want to be
better
i've done that in my marriage
several times
and
this may be a moment of clarification
for your marriage moving forward
he will never ever
talk to those knuckleheads on zoom
caller in person again those
relationships are over because you're
not going to be a part of those people's
lives and since y'all are one now he's
not either
and on and on and on
[Music]
but this conversation comes with a risk
either way
you are better on the other end of it
i'm heartbroken for you
and
we'll be walking alongside you on this
one thank you so much for being brave
and thank you for the call emma we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too to better
understand and improve your mental
relational and emotional health please
check out own your past change your
future at johndaloni.com today that's
johndaloney.com today
all right so as we wrap up today's show
andrew are we ready all right good
soldier sorry i busted in here and i
didn't follow the camera guy back there
making sure i don't look like an idiot
here's a tough tough job as we wrap up
today's show we're going with kelly's
favorite band she has a secret crush
on all of them
the beach boys
all of them
all of them
songs in my room and it goes like this
there's a world where i can go and tell
my secrets to in my room
in this world i lock out all my worries
and my fears in my room
do my dreaming and my scheme and lie
awake and pray do my crying and my sign
laugh at yesterday now it's dark and i'm
alone but i won't be afraid
in my room
maybe leave your room and find some
friends
go talk to other people we'll see you
soon
[Music]
coming up on the next episode how do you
have the
this is where babies come from with a
child that has been sexually abused
without it being a trigger thank you for
loving the kids in your community taking
one home
that puts you in rare air is it okay
that i don't really desire any
new friendships because of how much i
enjoy spending time with my wife what
i've seen happen over and over and over
and over time what happens pebble by
pebble by pebble is they drown their
spouse in their friendship one of the
most common questions i get is what is
gaslighting
it i get enraged i get so frustrated
angry